I think
the time being just past one o'clock on
June 27th I believe
um
this is
a subcommittee meeting of
um
the Judiciary Committee
and we are focusing on House Bill 533
relative
to public school human rights complaints
and
um
I'm representative Marjorie Smith I'm
the chair representative Kota mama left
is the vice chair and representatives
Paige Lanza and Tripp are our members
um our goal today is to figure out
um
uh what we're going to pursue in this
bill then we won't be doing anything
um
uh
uh except perhaps some independent
research between July and August and
we'll be back together again as a
subcommittee uh early in September
um
and does anyone on the committee have
anything they want to say at the
beginning
yes representative
so I had reached out to Richard Farrow
who is who does the investigations right
now just to understand better what he
actually was needing in order to do his
job and he was able to provide me with a
list of 13 kind of specific things that
he's looking into under the code of
conduct and I've passed them all down to
everybody so everybody should have a
copy
and I believe this would do this would
handle about
um 95 of of of what he does and so I
think this would be a good place perhaps
it's for us to start in looking in
because my sense from the group was that
we didn't want to make this
or that there was hesitation for making
a broad-based subpoena anything but more
we wanted it to be what was actually
needed we wanted to have some some
limitations on it so this is kind of a
draft of something perhaps that we could
consider working from
representative page I don't know how the
chairperson wants to proceed in terms of
how we take these things up but I I'm
not quite there yet in terms of what um
delineating what if any subpoena power I
from my perspective I still it's still
unclear to me
what the need is what the Department's
not getting
you know I think as we recall the
history of the bill
or the amendment came through
non-germaine Amendment it's a bit
contorted so from my perspective I'm
still I'm not quite at the
point of of
stipulating that there's a need for
because I don't I don't see it yet
so that would be one
issue I would would like to sort of
understand better through the summer and
then in the fall thank you very much
um anyone else want to say something
next
um
representative Lanza yes thank you
chairman um
um so I would also like to say the same
thing that I would like to
um not ready to just make any decisions
um today and I would like to have the
summer to discuss
um kind of look it over a little bit
better and be able to come up with some
kind of decision
I have good news for you representative
land so we are not going to make any
decisions today and so you are on Solid
Ground we're just trying to figure out
what the uh
what the issues are
um as uh representative page indicated
um
the way this came forward wasn't a
traditional way
um but
um nonetheless because of how we do
things in New Hampshire all of these
proposals get get good consideration our
representative Tripp that I see that you
were in the can you wanted to say
something
yes good go to it the uh I spent the
last couple days uh
researching you know what what this is
and uh as as representative page has has
mentioned that uh you know there was an
amendment that was brought forward which
uh
I think was
uh a solution to one of the the issues
that uh Ed Brunton brought up by uh
uh people that had testified
I'm uh my my dilemma is uh
uh a uh civil rights complaint is a
fairly broad area
and uh I I don't know what
uh what limits there would be
you know for uh
the Department of Education in
finally in a complaint for for a person
one of the the people that do not want
to file the complaint themselves so uh
like everyone else I'm a a little
confused I guess so like it uh
so it's a good thing we have the summer
too we get I'm confused thank you well
either to get unconfused or more
confused I can't say which it's going to
be but it will be one or the other
um I've also handed out to you
um a document that um
uh is based on material that I asked
Mr uh
lamp in OLS to prepare and that is to
tell us where
um
what
Commissioners have power of subpoena and
what are the circumstances under which
they have that power this is a document
unfortunately it doesn't have on it um
uh the source and and a date but it is
the research that was done by OLS and as
you look at it you can see um
that it's
um it's very specific
and
um and almost all have to do with
um
uh specific
Finance related matters
um so that you know you look at you know
at the page banking banking banking
banking banking banking banking
insurance
um and then
um
uh Agriculture and markets have a couple
and a natural and cultural resources and
in Environmental Services
um the one in Environmental Services has
to do exclusively with issues relating
to air pollution
control
and in natural cultural resources
relating to Mining and reclamation
so these are other than all the finance
ones these are very very narrow and very
specific
um
powers of subpoena
and uh
that exhausts the as I understand it and
I do trust Rich to be very thorough that
these are all of the examples
in state where a commissioner has the
power of subpoena of course we all know
that the Attorney General
has uh the power of subpoena and is
um
uh by by law and custom
responsible for providing
the legal
services for every Department even those
departments that have their own legal
counsel
um so that there might be some branches
of the Attorney General's office in each
of these agencies but the Attorney
General is at the top of the tree
um
representative I just I just noticed
that the liquor commissioner is missing
missing from this list so I just I
wanted us to maybe just add that to our
list it is RSA 179 uh 56. just so that
we're aware that's not on this list so
I'm not sure if it was missed or that
could be
um
because the Liquor Commission is not in
the traditional structure of
Commissioners in the government
they are
free
to function in a slightly different way
and that might be why it was left off
the list but I thank you very much for
that
um
is there anyone here from the Department
is there anything you would like to
share with us today
please sit down
I mean you know you could talk about the
rain I want to point out to everyone
that it has not yet rained 40 days and
40 nights so
we're home free so far
put on the bike and tell us who you are
just press that button down in the front
there you go okay my name is Richard
Farrell I'm an investigator for the
Department of Education I just began my
11th year doing this prior to that I
spent 30 years with the New Hampshire
State Police as a an investigator
trooper I know you appeared before the
committee when we heard the bill yes um
and we very much appreciated your
testimony then so one of the questions
that came up is the need
um one of the problems that we're having
is that as litigation increases between
school districts and school districts
attorneys superintendents and their
legal teams we are getting some
roadblocks put up to get information
concerning educated misconduct and I
provided 12 at the in the initial
hearing it was a little bit broad-based
we've tried to give you 12 examples
within the code of conduct to break it
down to be more specific and what we'd
be looking for
the biggest problem is that we are not
getting the information uh sometimes
from the school districts or the charter
schools their attorneys are telling us
that it's protected it's heavily
redacted sometimes they don't provide it
at all what we have been given on
occasion is the opportunity to come into
a legal office
to a conference room where we are given
the opportunity to review an internal
document
and we're told we cannot get a copy of
the internal document we cannot take uh
any uh copies of it uh we can make notes
from it and when the time comes for us
to go to take an action against an
educator or an in action against an
educator the attorneys for Nea for
example or American Federation of
teachers really good friends and we work
very well with them most of the time
they look at us and say show us the
report
well I can't give them the report
because it wasn't given to me
we've been brought into school districts
and here here you go here's the report
you cannot take it you cannot copy it
you cannot have it
in the discovery process under under the
due process rights the Educators have
requires us to provide all discovery
from our reports and any documents
associated with the alleged misconduct
to their Union attorneys
I can't provide it because they won't
provide it to me and a subpoena power
would allow us in limited circumstances
to get that internal document and
provide it in the course of the due
process rights that Educators have for
uh hearings
if we don't have it
we can't do it we can't provide it and
then it becomes significantly
problematic many times we had found
ourselves in that position I can recall
one instance in particular
we had the intention for us was to take
a certain action against an educator and
because we couldn't provide Discovery to
the educator and and his legal team we
negotiated the settlement that was far
less agreed file less serious than we
would have liked and sure enough within
two years that educator was back in
front of us with a similar alleged
misconduct
if we had had the subpoena power and the
full document to provide in Discovery we
may have had a different result and in
in these instances what we're talking
about
we're talking about whether or not some
teachers very small minority of teachers
engage in physical emotional sexual harm
to children and that's what we're trying
to focus on and that's the list of uh
the 12 items that we tried to break it
down and be more specific for you in our
document thank you very much you said
many times
um Can can you give me an idea of how
often
um
but you have met with resistance in
trying to get information that you feel
is necessary I I met with resistance
this week
and trying to get information from a a
source and we're negotiating I'm still
so close that I can get it but what
about in a month or a year or in a year
probably and keep in mind these are the
most egregious circumstances these are
the circumstances where there's
legitimate harm to children legitimate
harm in many instances sexual misconduct
and where you believe there is where we
believe the allegation requires us to
complete a thorough investigation right
and keep in mind
many times these allegations don't rise
to the level of a criminal act because
we work very closely with our law
enforcement Partners but they violate
the code of conduct where there's
grooming technique where there's
boundary issues where they violate Local
District policy and also the code of
conduct so in a course of of the year
um
how would you define many cases right
now we have from January 1st till now
we've drawn 55 cases
that 55 cases where where the total
cases where there is no cooperation no
55 total cases and within that 55 total
cases I would I would guess we're
looking at negotiations involving 10 of
the 55 cases where we're trying to get
more information and keep in mind
sometimes this information that we're
searching for isn't it doesn't
um
it doesn't rise to the level of a
misconduct allegation or misconduct
charge it exonerates the educator and
that's one of the things that I really
think you should be aware of many of
these cases come in we get the
information we're looking for and we
exonerate the educator as opposed to
take sanctions against them so in the
course of I would say in the course of a
year with a hundred drawn cases in a
full cases that we draw our numbers for
there are probably
15 cases where we have to negotiate very
strongly to try and get the information
that we need okay thank you that that's
very helpful and and can you help me
understand
why in those cases where you believe you
have strong reason to pursue them
um the Attorney General's power
um is not helpful to you well I've done
the research on this and I've been
knocking on this door for for over 10
years now and I'm told that the Attorney
General's office does not have the
authority to seek a subpoena for a third
party investigation or a third party
division or section of government that's
what we're told if if in fact it was
true if it were true that they would
provide subpoena power for us then I
would have done that 10 years ago
but they don't if I remember what
when you when you appeared before us and
you had a lot of information for us then
um you said that this 10 years ago this
wasn't a problem that people cooperated
so you wouldn't have had a case that
it's been more recent 10 years ago we
had a greater cooperation in the front
end of Investigations and as time has
progressed uh that cooperation level has
changed uh the world is the world has
changed yes it certainly has there's no
question about it
um I certainly hope so if it's for the
good but a lot of it isn't
um
does anyone yes representative Tripp
uh
the investigations that you conduct yes
these are all directly related to code
of conduct violations correct are there
any other investigations types or is it
strictly code of conduct so the only
other thing outside of the code of
conduct that I would involve myself in
is assisting the Bureau of credentialing
with criminal background checks to say
to clarify for example here's a criminal
background check on a new teacher
candidate and they're confused as to
what the background what the criminal
background check says so I'll I'll
assist them by saying look Nel Pros
means it doesn't exist anymore so it
looks like a very heinous event or crime
that's been charged and I would come
down and say no no this no longer exists
and you'll look at the arrest date you
look at the disposition date and the
disposition is no prostate dismissed so
I help them guide them through criminal
background checks but other than that my
investigation is a code of conduct
violations and there are five sections
of the code of conduct and I that's
that's my Lane code of conduct
uh
fine thank you uh one of the uh as I
mentioned earlier
uh I've been doing a bit of research on
on this because I I thought it was
supposed to be a little bit prepared uh
one of the things I believe I read is
that the uh uh deep
when there is a complaint
uh it is typically given to
uh the superintendent or a designee
and uh
they will conduct the investigation on
the code of conduct or or whatever the
complaint is about uh is that something
that has some
truth to it well the superintendents and
school districts had the obligation and
the duty to investigate violations of
their policies and procedures which they
do and sometimes those violations of
policies of procedures intersect with
the code of conduct and it's in those
instances where we work together with
the school superintendents with their
designated persons which includes
third-party law firms or investigators
and it's when policy and code of conduct
intersect that we work together
it's representative Paige
thank you uh thanks welcome again
um
I'm having trouble following all this to
be frank
um because from the beginning we had a
bill dealing with Human Rights
Commission
violations and then we have now a
non-germaine amendment that we're we're
dealing with with subpoena power
if my recollection serves I wouldn't
guarantee it but we can go back and
check
when you were here and whenever it was
March or February you indicated to the
committee that you were successful with
your job I am
and that the idea of a subpoena power
would be a prospective power another I
think
I think attorney Fenton might have used
the term tool toolbox but I'm not sure
that that was that was the position at
that at that point is that
Fair it's fair to say that during my 10
years
we have had some cooperation we have had
great cooperation from some places and
districts we've had less from others I'm
I'm pretty good at my job and I try the
best I can to accomplish the mission But
as time has progressed closer to today
I'm getting more and more pushback
from entities that are not giving us the
full information that we're asking for
and I understand it completely
you know there's a lot of litigation
involved the unions involved the
people's lives are involved and
I just am running into more difficulty
getting information that will either
help teachers out of a jam or
move forward to keep teachers that
shouldn't be around kids around kids
so
if I could continue do I need can I just
run a little bit sure for not too long I
don't don't worry
um if I stand up and leave okay that's
good that's good so so I guess I'll ask
an open-ended question I mean
what what somewhat open is a dangerous
one I guess if it's open-ended but
you know what what's changed I mean are
the school districts now recalcitrin to
to investigate or help the doe find
people who might be violating some of
these uh Provisions I mean these are
pretty serious
let me I mean these are pretty serious
Provisions here I I I'm having a tough
time seeing why a school superintendent
would find it in their interest or a
school district to
not ask or not not be helpful if they
had information setting aside whether
they're mandatory reporters setting
aside the employment consequences that
they're probably investigating if these
things are any close to being true I
mean what what's changed that would
position assuming there's a number of
them out there superintendents the
school districts from striking the
posture that we're not going to
cooperate that's that's not the posture
the superintendent's taking
superintendents want to cooperate
cooperate to the greatest level possible
however many superintendents are
designating the investigations to law
firms or third-party investigators and
that's where the greatest problem comes
in I'll give you an example we were
brought in to a local school district
where there was a sexual misconduct of a
young boy by a a coach
and
we looked at the chain of command and
how the report was failed to come
through their inner chain of command
they missed a lot of steps and they
reported It ultimately because they
became aware of it and he the
superintendent cooperated to the
greatest level and extent possible
there was an internal report done that
documented from A to Z
what happened when it happened the dates
the times the locations and we were
offered the opportunity to go into a law
firm sit at a uh a conference send in a
conference room in the conference room
desk they gave us a document they said
take all the time you need you can't you
can't copy it you can't disseminate it
take what you want
we want to take action against an
educator involved in the misconduct the
first question we got from the attorney
representing the educator was show us
the discovery
they knew there was a there was a third
party investigation
show us the discovery I couldn't show
them the discovery because we were not
allowed to have the discovery so we we
had to go by notes
go by parent interviews go by student
interviews and we were able to get
something out of that misconduct the
allegation but we weren't able to get
what should have happened
you're all familiar with the the
conquered case the infamous conquered
case uh where Mr lewing has now just
pleaded guilty to multiple constant
sexual assault involving a middle school
girl
we were not allowed to have that copies
of that information the superintendent
the principal the superintendent This
legal team for the for the district
initially did not give us any of that
information then we would had difficulty
trying to get uh information from the
local police that wasn't redacted
we we were successful ultimately in
getting the license revoked but it took
us a far longer to do it
it took us great far more difficulty in
getting it done and Discovery again
became a problem
so the thing that's changed is that the
school district attorneys are now saying
don't give this information
or they're allowing you to review it in
camera if you will correct so you are
seeing it you are seeing the data the
evidence the we're seeing the
information dates so
so
is there has there been a change in and
maybe there's someone from the school
boards that could help us with this but
has there been a change in
litigation Theory where the school
districts up until you know two years
ago have now decided they're
going to take this approach assuming
that's what they're doing again it's not
all it's some and there is a there is a
change and there is a concern for
litigation and I think that that's where
the holdup is and allowing us to have
subpoena power to go in and get that
full document for full Discovery would
be helpful in going after or exonerating
Educators or going after the education
shouldn't be there anymore so just one
one more if you don't mind it when there
are other ways to get you know there are
other ways to get the information
outside of the document that you review
in a school district office right I mean
if you were able to and I don't mean to
be testy about it but I'm but I'm trying
to understand if you see the document
with the information
um there seems to be if that is valuable
information you've got it
right and so you have a way to figure
out and that may be part of the
investigative process and assuming this
has happened assuming it's happened on
multiple cases but I would be curious to
to get more information on that but
you know if if you've seen the document
in the room with the information
you have the information just not in the
document well we have the information we
don't have the document which means the
the the the the other side the attorneys
representing the accused educator are
looking for that document
and we can't give it to them but you
would and I'm I'll you would be able to
verify that information or seek and
invest through your own investigate
process to be able to sort of whatever
the document says about whomever and
whenever to sort of use this sleuthing
power to to probably figure out that and
get it without that and be able I can
independently well first of all the
document is heavily redacted so that's
part of the problem
it's all very definitely redacted in
terms of FERPA protections of students
the other problem is the the people that
are representing the educator know it
exists
and I can't give it to them
so I can go out I can do everything I
can I can go find the kid I can go find
the parents I can go find the Educators
and try and fill in the missing pieces
which I do
but sometimes I don't
and at the end of the day any good
attorney is going to in the discovery
process say where are the documents
and if I can't provide them then we're
now in a negotiating phase
I guess there are more than one ways to
establish a fact besides the document
that's produced by the school district
but what you've just said you were able
to do so
I'll I'll stop and I know representative
Tripp has some questions
apparently
um
you say that the uh the investigation
which uh is
initiated by the superintendent no
investigations for us are not initiated
by the superintendent the investigations
are initiated by superintendents
self-reporting which they are required
to do if they're aware of it they come
to us from the police they come to us
from Individual individual parents they
come from us from dcyf reports
those are how we get our investigations
some some are self-reported by the
superintendent
that's true and the superintendents do
conduct investigations they either
designate someone within the chain of
command if the school is big enough the
school district is big enough or they
hire third party either law firms or
third party investigators to come in and
conduct those investigations
so they do conduct investigations but
they're not the only source of
Investigations
I went I called a superintendent on
Monday of this week and said we have a
problem I have a report from dcyf
indicating that one of your staff
members is engaged in misconduct
superintendent said what are you talking
about
and at that point I gave him the
information over the phone he goes I'll
be in touch with my attorney I'll be in
touch with you we'll start our internal
investigation that's how that works
sometimes the opposite occurs where the
superintendent says calls the phone and
said Rich we have a problem I put a
teacher on an admin leave today this is
the allegation we're going to start an
internal process and then we parallel
that if it's a if it is a code of
conduct violation very narrow
if it's code of conduct violation
that's how it works it's not one size
fits all and the information comes to us
from multiple sources five in particular
and many times they come from Individual
parents and this time of year you'd be
amazed at how many complaints commit
parents are hypersensitive to
retaliation against their children they
wait until school's out and the phone
rings off the hook
this is what happened to my child this
week this is what happened to my child
in February we're getting those kinds of
complaints and then we reach back out to
the superintendents so the
superintendent does his his or her job
but that's not the only source of our
information and that's the only those
aren't the only sources of the complaint
again please yes uh you mentioned
several times that there's lawyers
involved are are the lawyers
working for
the superintendent
the Union
or the teacher all of the above all the
above so there could be a number of
lawyers that you have to deal with yes
thank you
when
um
you talk about initiating against
subpoena
um
who is being subpoenaed who or what
so what documents Instagram do you know
every sexual misconduct case involving
an educated allegation again involving
an educator every single one of those
allegations begins with social media
every single one of them
and we have no access to social media
this would not change it at all sure it
would
we could reach out and subpoena
documents from the carriers
foreign
we know that there's significant
difficulty in um
you have to understand that I'm a
Luddite I I do not believe in social
media I think social media it provides
much more of a negative presence in our
society than a positive presence I do
not use social media I do not have a
social media account all that but I know
how important social media is in terms
of how people get information I also
know that it's very difficult
to get to subpoena social media to get
the results that you need
um
I can't see
why having
the commissioner
of any agency have the power to subpoena
is more likely to achieve success than
having the Attorney General
subpoena
and
I also don't think he'll have success
but that's beside the point um
am I wrong on that well first of all
right now we have no access
and sometimes if a crime has occurred
involving a teacher
law enforcement will take the action
they need to to try and preserve the
information on social media and then get
it which happened in the the conquered
case for example and then we were able
to at some point we were able to get
some of that information for the
licensing issue because all we care
about is the licensing issue so it is
possible to get it through subpoena
right now I have no access to it
whatsoever especially if no crime has
occurred
that's a big problem we have a case
right now that came in on on last Friday
we're working on it now the Educators
out on administrative leave and what
we've already determined is that the
educator was sending pictures of himself
in various stages to a 16 year old girl
and the 16 year old girl was likewise
sending images of herself to the
educator now we we have a problem with
that alleged too no it's no it's not
alleged any longer okay I just okay fine
so it's not alleged in any way shape or
form it's there we we have gotten access
to it because of the parent that
provided it provided that information to
us and so what power what would subpoena
power give you that you don't have now
potentially getting the information from
law enforcement
the carrier itself
especially in the instances where
there's no crime alleged
where the of Educators violating
boundaries but hasn't committed a crime
really yeah 16 year old
well
representative give it a question
I just I wanted to point out I think
that there's kind of some crossoverlap
here because
when the bill originally came in it was
really to put
it was to give the authority of the
education or commissioner to put rights
over to the Human Rights Commission and
it wasn't really related to the code of
conduct it was more related to
discrimination and I think that that's
why that there's some confusion but now
when we got the non-germaine amendment
it was something that was completely
unrelated to that and this isn't towards
looking into
discrimination but this is more like for
you to do your job looking into
um mainly the list that you gave us is
abuse and neglect is that a correct
understanding that this is kind of an
entirely separate thing than what we're
originally looking at in the non when
the non-germain amendment was made that
the Discrimination piece isn't really
what you're looking at now now it's
really to get into the code of conduct
for abuse and neglect is that correct
it's just to clarify it's not really
what I'm asking for it's what I'm asking
for
uh we're not involved in hb2 whatsoever
we're not involved in any of the
provisions for the Human Rights
Commission we're not involved in the
discrimination case that's not in the
code of conduct
therefore that's nothing to do with me
and since hb2 was passed I have
investigated exactly zero cases involved
with hb2 zero
and when you say hb2
to what are you referring human rights
discrimination
um
the the things that people are most
concerned about as it involved in House
Bill too the the the idea that we're
going to come in and investigate
allegations of
um
discrimination racial discrimination
lgbtq that's not my wheelhouse that's
not what I do that's not in the code of
conduct that's not what I do but there's
nothing in hb2 that well that's the
so-called hb2 I just I just spent nine
and a half hours being deposed by the
ACLU and all we talked about was hb2 but
well you must be exhausted I can
understand that but if what you're
talking about
um
well it doesn't we'll let that go by I
mean I can explain so there I have the
memo on it that actually came from uh
the doj so it was
um
it was hb2 it's just saying that
the parts that he's saying that he can't
look into from hb2 were the teaching of
the children that
um
a certain identified group is inherently
Superior inferior to people of another
identified group or sexist or whatever
um and those are the the pieces that
he's saying that he's not looking into
that came from hb2 that went into RSA
193. correct and in fact
to all of our knowledge
um
there is there anyone in any school
district
um that um
teaches that one group is Superior or
inferior to another I have no idea I
don't look into it not not my business
representative page
um is
um
I guess I guess I guess I'm wondering
if this is a plausible line of thought
that although we started with the doe
having some sort of prosecutorial powers
for H for the divisive Concepts law that
was the original Bill we then had a
non-germaine Amendment dealing with
subpoena powers
and we
wasn't all together at least from my
perspective wasn't altogether clear what
the need was in fact
you know you seem very successful at
getting the information and getting
to the bottom of bad situations
um but I'm wondering if you if you could
just take off your investigator hat for
a moment and
is it plausible to think that there
might be a healthy degree of skepticism
given the track record of how the bill
and the amendment came in and
you know perhaps
what seems to be a very politically
contentious
situation between
teachers and and the commission at the
department
at the moment you're right the first
time
the commissioner right yeah so okay well
so so yes so it does seem I wonder if
you'd grant that it's a plausible
um line of thought to think of the the
bill with the current political
situation I understand your your
position I understand your question uh
it was not my decision at all to have
this as an amendment to that bill
um I understand completely why there's
concern
um I'm just telling you what I do and
how I do it uh frankly
um I think it's a tool that we need and
moving forward in the litigious society
that we're in I think it's definitely
necessary but I can understand your
position and anyone else's position all
of a sudden you have a Human Rights
Commission action and now you're
sticking a subpoena palette to it and
the first thing you would think of and
if if I were a teacher in the field I
would think okay so the commissioner the
department is trying to get subpoena
power for that and it's not the case I
don't I don't think it was a wise move
to do the amendment the way it was done
but it's not my call it's not my job I'm
just trying to testify as to I need and
that's that's what I want to stick to I
would have done it differently
anything else
of course we'll see you again Ashley
representative
I know that there are people that are
probably going to be upset with this
question but uh
do you sense that uh
in the
the
it's more important to protect teachers
now than it is to protect the students
no I don't I don't agree with that I
think everyone wants to protect kids
I think there's that's the number one
Focus I think superintendents the
lawyers representing them the
investigators school boards everyone
wants to to protect the kids and I
disagree with the notion that it's uh
the we're spending too much time uh
protecting teachers I I just disagree
with the premise I think that this is a
politically sensitive topic
and I'm just trying to do my job to
protect kids from teachers that are
predators that shouldn't be in
classrooms and the idea that teachers
are the problem are that people
representing teaches the problem that's
absolutely wrong categorically wrong
everyone is focusing on the health and
the safety of the kids it's just how we
get there
thank you anything else thank you very
much
um chairman Ladd did you have anything
you wanted to contribute to this
conversation I I see you're here and I
want to acknowledge your presence
would you come come up so that we could
yes
the chair recognizes
representative Ladd who's chairman of
the House Education committee
thank you very much Madam chair
uh for the record my name is Rick Ladd I
chair House Education here in Concord
um
I'm here primarily to listen and to
become more familiar with what we have
going on in this particular bill
I I just you know hope everybody has a
copy of this booklet right here
this is the code of ethics and code of
conduct for New Hampshire Educators I I
have an extra copy I could provide the
committee here and I think it's worthy
that you have that we would very much
appreciate that
um back in 2022 we had a bill come
before the education committee which was
not this bill of course but it was HP
1336 and through our study and looking
in that and working with teachers
and school administrators and the school
board we saw some issues within the code
of conduct when it comes to reprimand or
suspension or revoking revoking the
credential that there's probably another
level that has to be considered and it's
in the letter that I wrote right here
this administrative letter to the
department based upon the
recommendations of the House Education
committee we rather see things taken
care of through the rulemaking process
than through stash story changes so I'll
I'll get a copy of this maybe I can give
a copy to Jen Jen could make a copy for
you so you can see that we have been
discussing the code of conduct
and it's not a perfect document but it's
one that we put in place several years
ago because we recognize the need to be
Havoc conduct in terms of the student
parents the community the profession
and I think it's been a very valuable
instrument that we've had since then uh
I I either probably is a need that we
look at some of that and especially when
it comes to the latter part the
reporting stages and the uh discipline
when you see an issue that may or may
not be going on so I'll stop right there
I was here primarily today Madam chair
to listen see where we're going with
this
well thank you very much and those two
items your letter yeah um and and the uh
this letter was written on behalf of the
committee but at the recommendation of a
small group in which we met and I
believe one of those that met with us is
sitting behind me
um directly behind me and uh I think
it's where we all were at that time and
probably still are in terms of the
change that we were recommending
thank you that's that's very very
helpful
um and and we have heard before you came
in that we're talking about a very small
number of cases
um where the level of cooperation isn't
what we would all
uh hope for but even though it's small
it still has to be acknowledged that's
correct we thank you very much and I I
think um our wonderful researcher can
help make sure that we all have copies
of both yes thank you very much thank
you very much
um representative Perez you indicated
that you wanted to speak
Christine Perez I'm speaking as a parent
as a grandparent and um
as an individual who has seen things
that have gone wrong
to answer a question about why now
because during covid
when parents were sitting with their
children at home while the children were
being educated a lot of things came out
and they became more aware of things
that were going on at the school so
started digging a lot deeper so I
personally I believe that that's one of
the reason on my way up here I saw one
of the big neon signs that we put up
that said I think 45 traffic deaths this
year one is too many I want you to think
about the fact that one one
teacher that has hurt a child and is
allowed to continue is one too many so
the number
as far as I'm concerned of how many he
does it just takes one one of the
problems that happens and it's my
understanding in speaking at the
Department of Education and talking to
them is sometimes the questionable
Acts or questionable
um
encounter never make it to the DOE they
get negotiated with at the principal and
superintendent level and then
they get to make an agreement and it
gets sealed
and that never makes it to the DOE
and then that teacher might go to
another District
and have the same type of activity
happen
and it never makes it to the DOE
I'm not talking about criminal I'm
talking about just perhaps under
criminal but inappropriate education for
a kid and it gets sealed again
so by the time perhaps it might reach
the doe there may be two or three sealed
that were never brought forward but yet
this educator or employee was allowed to
go
from institution to Institution
those things if perhaps the doe
hypothetically became aware that there
might have been something and goes back
to a previous school if that
superintendent refuses to give it they
have no information for it
I want you to think about the fact that
most Educators do not do break the code
of conduct most Educators don't
most doctors are good too and I was a
nurse for 42 years most of them but
there have been nurses that have been
nurse Killers we've seen movies about it
it just takes one and to it make it
easier for them to do their job to stop
this from happening to another child I
think is very important
um
things are much different than they were
a few years ago and I think parents do
the Pat or the part about having your
child's a Target on your child's back
has been going on for many years I have
a 43 year old daughter I was on the
Hollis School Board she was in sixth
grade I voted against a raise her sixth
grade teacher
would not let her go to the bathroom
her sixth grade teacher would not answer
her when she raised her hands to the
point where my her father and I had to
hire a lawyer and go to a school this
was in a little tiny town of Brookline
back in sixth grade 92
so parents are afraid to speak up and
that's why he's being inundated at this
time be aware Please be aware and
consider that there are teachers and
there are staff members that are not
perfect and these people need to be able
to do their job to protect
to protect
the child
that's who we're here to protect the
child and sometimes allegations can be
made against a staff member that are
unwarranted by a angry parent so you're
not only protecting the child
but in some cases you could be
protecting
the staff member as well against
unwarranted allegations so I just ask
you to keep those things in mind thank
you very much any questions thank you
very much is there anyone else here who
would like to speak
thank you madam chair and good afternoon
members of of the subcommittee my name
is Barrett Christine I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
boards Association
um by way of background I was on the
committee that wrote the code of conduct
back in I believe 2018 it was
um and um I also want to uh just on
behalf of the school boards Association
want to thank Mr Farrell for his time
and effort and in working basically to
protect kids which is
um you know certainly what what I tell
school words all the time aside from
academics see your first priority is to
make sure that kids are safe when
they're when they're within the walls of
your school
um there's a lot to unpack here
I've got a lot of different thoughts but
I want to be mindful of the committee's
time today and perhaps bring some of
those thoughts back at a subsequent
meeting but
um I want to go back to the beginning
um over to the Genesis of of the
original bill
um and sort of how we got here today
because there's some points in the
original bill that I think are worthy of
discussion relative to some comments
that Mr Farrell made a few minutes ago
if we go back to the original bill it
was to allow the Department of Education
to file complaints on behalf of parents
to file with the Human Rights Commission
for alleged violations of RSA 193
um 38 39 and 40. RSA 193 40 paragraph
four violation of this section by an
educator shall be considered a violation
of the educator code of conduct that
justifies disciplinary sanction by the
State Board of Education so a violation
of this whatever we want to call this
bill the anti-discrimination bill or the
anti-anti-discrimination bill whatever
name we're gonna we're gonna give we're
going to give it
um
they included um that a violation of
that was was a violation of that statute
was a violation of the code of conduct
Mr Farrell just said that there have
been no credible violations that have
crossed his desk relative to RSA 193 38
39 and 40.
I surmised that that is why the bill was
put in in the first place
so the department could file these
coax the language out the way the
department wanted to
alleged way it would want to and then
there'd be an alleged violation of the
statute not filed by the parent the
filed by the by the department in an
effort to then pursue cases of educator
misconduct both under the statute and
then under the teacher code of conduct
it's very very interesting that none of
these allegations under the
anti-anti-discrimination statute have
come forward to the Human Rights
Commission or have crossed Mr Farrell's
desk but yet we had a bill last year
saying that somehow this was needed
somehow this was needed somehow this was
needed let me just interrupt you for one
moment
um uh Mr Farrell talked about hb2 you
are talking about the same correct oh
language it's just that when it was
incorporated into rsas
um it was under those three sections
that you just alluded to correct thank
you very much Madam chair yes um these
provisions of Statute and RSA 193 that I
referred to were included in House Bill
2 in 2019 for a variety of reasons
um so with that background I find it
interesting it's just very interesting
that Mr Farrell was saying that none of
the allegations under this
anti-anti-discrimination statute have
either one Cross disaster two have not
risen to a level of a violation of the
code of conduct which is a very peculiar
that we had a bill
seeking to give the department authority
to be the one to file and write these
complaints it's very very peculiar the
other aspect that I think is is is is is
important for the for the committee to
for for the community to be mindful of
when Mr Farrell testified
um on the proposed amendment February
March whenever that was
um he said that parents are weaponizing
the code of conduct
um
you know I don't know what that means
specifically I don't know if that means
that they're filing false allegations
with the Department of Education or the
allegations that they are filing are not
um credible or if they simply don't rise
to the level of a violation under the
code of conduct but I went back and
watched that testimony to make sure I
had his language right Mr Farrell said
that parents are weaponizing the code of
conduct
um so that should be a very very
important
um consideration for whatever this
committee you know does it whatever
comes out at the end of this committee
or whatever legislation may be filed
um next fall the last aspect well maybe
not the last but one other aspect that
um I would encourage the committee to do
if you have not already take a look at
Department of Education role Ed 511 511
that's the Department of Education rule
that sort of lays out the process for
complaints cases and investigations
um and it's about it's not too along to
about maybe four or five pages again
that's Ed 5 11.
um and just I'll read it if I you
indulge me just for a second or two the
opening paragraph says a case shall be
opened when a complaint of possible
misconduct against a credentialed holder
has come to the attention of the
department either through direct
reporting or other means
the next paragraph after an initial
review if the department determines that
a possible violation of the code of
conduct has occurred and investigations
shall be open so I can't speak to that I
presume Mr Farrell can at some point but
a parent calls in or a superintendent
calls in to to make a statement to Mr
Farrell or attorney Fenton a case is
opened and then they do some preliminary
investigation and then if they believe
you know it's warranted an investigation
is open so there's a case in
investigation relative to that nhsba's
position would be that
um if if the department is going to be
granted subpoena power
um there needs to be sort of a
triggering effect to that we talked
about due to the you know you can go
broad brushed or you can go very narrow
there's probably something in between I
don't want to say what that would be
without really giving a consideration
looking at language looking at other
states things of that nature
um but if if the department is going to
be given um subpoena power there should
be one a triggering event and two there
should be parameters and criteria most
specifically and I've talked about this
a little bit when um when we had the the
hearing on the amendment
um if there's going to be subpoena power
issued there needs to be guard rails and
safeguards for for parents and students
we spent we meeting this legislative
body both both houses spent a lot of
time this session talking about parental
rights if a student is going to her
child is going to be subpoenaed
um it would make sense to me that the
parent should be notified and the
parents should be given some option as
to whether or not to quash The subpoena
that usually involves hiring an attorney
and an additional cost or there should
be some sort of opt-out we hear about
parents being able to opt out of all
sorts of things in the educational realm
these days testing curriculum whatever
it might be so it seems to me that there
should be at least some some
notification to parents some explanation
to parents of a document drawn up either
by the Department of Education or the
Attorney General's office outlining what
the parental rights are in case the
student gets subpoenaed or in case
Student Records get subpoenaed and then
give parents some sort of options within
that that would be consistent with a lot
of the tone of a lot of bills this year
throughout the legislature
um I think those are the only comments I
have right now again there's a lot to
unpack here uh the school boards
Association will certainly be attending
you know the further committee meetings
whether or not over the summer or over
the fall
um we're also here um we're happy to
offer um our assistance to the committee
um uh you know whatever resources that
we could help with we're happy to do
that
um I know um you know Jen is often
overwhelmed and overloaded despite the
amazing work that she does um you know I
know it's only one person
um but you know we obviously have the
school board just New Hampshire school
boards Association has
um you know contacts with 49 other state
school boards associations and we can
tap into those as to what their
departments are doing what their laws
are saying
um how the investigative power I'm sorry
how The subpoena Powers with their
department and uh lie and and so on and
so forth so if there's anything that the
committee needs assistance with by all
means please reach out to myself or or
Becky Wilson our director governmental
relations as well too and we're happy to
help the community in whatever way we
can so I think that's it um for me today
my comments today and I'm happy to
answer any questions that the that the
subcommittee may have
thank you very much are there any
questions representative Paige thanks
thank you um do you know if the
Department of Education can currently
ask the Attorney General's office for a
subpoena if they needed one for some
thank you for the question I don't know
the answer to that
and if follow-up if I may have if if
they could would that be a
a guardrail
that would certainly be one guard rail
absolutely
um you know sort of the same way that um
I believe I believe the Attorney
General's office is investigating
complaints that come in under the
anti-anti-discrimination law if that
complaint initially comes to the
Department of Education it's my
understanding that the Attorney
General's office is reviewing them first
to see if they have Merit before they're
passed on to the Human Rights Commission
so there's only some interplay relative
to maybe not directly related to
subpoena power but certainly within the
realm of what we've been talking about
relative to the original bill in the
amendment thank you
representative
so just so I'm understanding correctly
thank you for taking my question thank
you for letting me ask
would you
what I heard you say I just want to make
sure I'm understanding correctly that
generally speaking that you're you
support the bill as long as there's
safeguards and parameters in place to
make sure that you know there's some
protection going on with it is that is
that a fair yeah I don't want to put
words in your mouth thank you very much
um for the for the question
representative I mean you know the
lawyer in me I'm a member of the bar I'm
going to say well I want to see the bill
first but those sorts of guard rails and
safeguards notice the parents protecting
the parents rights giving them Options
under whether it's a memorandum from the
Department that would go a long way in
in helping nhsba support the bill
thank you
because you made yourself vulnerable by
saying you were a lawyer first
um
what we heard earlier is that
um the superintendent might have an
individual superintendent and again
we're speaking about very very few
people I keep on wanting I make that
same point but I think it's important to
make again and again that the
superintendent might have been
um willing and previously might have
cooperated but
um as soon as the temperature rises so
to speak an attorney is hired and then
it would appear that the attorney
takes over and tells the superintendent
no you may not share this or that or
whatever
I was always under the impression that
the attorney worked for
the person who retained her services and
am I wrong about that thank you for the
question representative to be clear
though I am and I'll get to your your
answer in a second representative
um to be clear
um though I am an attorney and we have a
staff attorney on staff at nhsb we don't
provide direct legal services to school
districts we provide training General
Legal Information is there a statute
that says this and you point them in the
right direction
um uh so the dis the attorneys that Mr
Farrell referenced and presumably works
with they are representing the district
as a as a corporate entity and then
obviously the school board and the
superintendent have fiduciary duties and
responsibilities to the district as a
whole I mean one of those is obviously
protecting kids but it's also
maintaining Fidelity and adherence to
other laws such as student privacy laws
student confidentiality laws staff
confidentiality laws so on and so forth
so but the attorney itself the attorney
as you as you ask Madam chair is
representing the district as an entity
and is not representing the teacher per
se or not representing the
superintendent per se at least in the
context of the phone calls that Mr
Farrell or attorney Fenton would make
saying may I have these documents may
have these documents
I'm interested to hear what you say
um
because I know for example we have a
great deal of evidence that in special
education matters there are very few law
firms that specialize on in in
representing uh school school districts
but
they do a very good job in that
representation and they also get paid
um
by the hour so that it is in the
attorney's personal interest to what I
would
perhaps intolerantly refer to as churn
to say to the principal the school
superintendent whatever oh we're not
going to
acknowledge the legitimate need of
special education here because why
should we pay for it let's just keep on
challenging it ending up probably
spending more money on legal fees than
they would have paid for the special
education and we know that that happens
and it happens again and again so
my concern is
when I listen to to the testimony that
it is the lawyers who say don't
cooperate or we won't share the document
you can't take the document out it's not
necessarily in the best interest of the
child it is probably in the best
interest of the attorney
um thank you for the question statement
well it really was a preparation I would
guess if I um
a bad lawyer can make a case drag on for
years a good lawyer can make a case drag
on even longer
oh my goodness gracious I mean I I don't
respectfully representative you know
they're they're about 40 attorneys in
the state that
um that work with school districts some
of them it's 100 of their caseload
others it may be 10 or 15 percent of the
caseload
um but we're not going to name names no
no no but but well they do other things
you know they may have you know they may
represent a district in a in a right to
no law case but they may do some
landlord tenant stuff for drafting wills
and you know trust that you know as well
you know I don't you know I
plenty of jokes can be made about
attorneys doing it for the money you
said they bill by the hour they they
bill every six or ten minutes depending
on what the depending on what their
firm's practice is so I mean are the
attorneys doing it to rack up their
bills I certainly hope not
I guess my my question was that
are we do we have a problem here with
the school administration
or do we have a problem with legal
representation of the school
administration because that's a
different matter sure and I think
but again respectfully representative I
don't you asked do we have a problem
with the administration or a problem
with the attorneys I don't think there's
a problem with either of them I think
the I think the superintendents are
doing what they can do in the best
interest of of students and keeping
students safe and the attorneys are
doing the best that they can do to
advise the school district in their in
the superintendent on how to proceed
under a myriad of very complex laws
whether it's special education student
privacy you know FERPA Student Records
there's a there's a there's a myriad of
very
complex issues at play when when student
records and staff records that are
otherwise exempt from disclosure under
both state and federal law are being
asked to turn over to somebody you know
who's
you know to an agency who's
motives may be in question
thank you any anything else yes
representative I won't having made a
living on those six minute increments I
won't I won't take offense to the chairs
questioning but but uh
um here is a question
um even that going back to that
um sort of in-camera review of this
document that might exist about yeah
whatever it is and I recognize that the
school district may be the school board
or whatever may be the the client at the
end of the day you know it's
it's not the superintendent versus so
and so it's you know
Exeter School essays right the district
is either the plaintiff or the defendant
right so so but in that moment when the
superintendents sort of been charged
with their responsibilities and they're
making these day-to-day calls
wouldn't it be fair to say that the
superintendent would have that or
discretion in terms of
um that document release if he's
listening to his legal counsel I know
that some may be more cautious and may
say well I'm gonna run this through
executive session or what have you but
I'm wondering if that that would be a
possibility wouldn't it certainly thank
you for the question representative I
mean part of it would have to be what is
being asked to be produced you know it
it take take take out the The subpoena
power aspects just for a second and the
code of conduct just for a second
you know you get a voluminous right to
know law request under 91a a
superintendent can look at it and say
you know yeah these five things we know
are public records I can disclose those
right now these five things that are
being asked for I need to run it by
Council because I really have no idea
and and and the exemption statute RSA
9185 documents that are exempt from
disclosure that's a mess that statute is
a mess it's complex it's convoluted it's
vague you know representative we've had
numerous numerous right to know law
bills the last 10 years in this in this
room and there's always trying to tweak
it so you know does a superintendent
have some discretion with that but you
know as I said we're soft in the first
line we don't give direct legal advice
if a superintendent called me and said
we got a subpoena from the Department
asking for these 10 things I'd say you
need to call Private Council I said
don't try and figure that out for
yourself why why take a risk making a
mistake and disclosing something that
should not be disclosed and contains
private confidential information that's
sort of the other thing too I didn't
mention this but you got me going on it
representative I'm speaking to the guard
rails as we as we talked about I know
there are some Provisions in FERPA the
federal education rights Privacy Act
that relates to Student Records and he
can't be disclosed without you know
parental consent there's there is a
subpoena exception in there but there
should we should also put some guard
rails in whatever statue comes out of
this is
what is the department going to do with
those records once they have them and
how long are they going to retain them
for are they destroyed are they what are
they kept in a file if there's an
investigation I don't I don't know that
there may be a law enforcement aspect of
that that I'm simply not aware of but
another another aspect for the
committee's consideration
and I hope I answered your question
representative thank you thank you
thank you very much anything else
um thank you for your time it was very
helpful if you do want to
um
put in writing your initial statement
um and send it to us we would appreciate
that it would
um
we need to add to our body of knowledge
and we recognize that with that's what
we're committed to we don't know we
don't have a final determination we
don't know
and if this were easy we wouldn't be
sitting here right we know it's very
complicated and
um any information that helps inform us
um would be welcome and so I appreciate
your willingness is there anyone else
thank you very much thank you is there
anyone else Madam chair could I just
make one layer one thing on to that
comment that you were just
um with respect to the information that
you might find you you run in the
circles of school boards and
superintendents and so on and perhaps
there's a way for you to um distill to
what extent if any
um you know this this resistance if you
will that seems to be new
either a exists and why
um you know so I'm not asking you to
answer that now or you may say I'm not
going to answer it but that's fine but
just in terms of your calling
information sure just to make sure I'm
clear on the question so as to why
things are different today than they
were perhaps 10 years ago was that the
question I must have missed what you're
actually yeah so so part of the
conversation I think we're having today
was um this idea that um
for whatever reason superintendents or
school districts are reluctant to give
any information that might be helpful to
the doe in that investigation you know
of alleged an activity bad activity so
something's changed because that seems
to be new and and and it seems from the
timeline so you know is that occurring
at what extent you know and then uh if
so what explains it if we don't right I
I prefer to give that some more thought
if that's okay oh yeah yeah I don't want
you to answer it now I mean like a
deliberative thought on it right thank
you very much thank you madam chair
thank you um
anyone else here who would like to add
to our knowledge
or subtract from our knowledge I mean
that's also possible
um
thank you I just want to make sure
anyone who wanted to be heard was heard
um
the question is are we
better situated now than we were an hour
and a half ago in terms of
being able to define the problem
and uh
pursue possible Avenues of resolving the
problem
I guess the answer is probably yes and
no
um
we as a as a subcommittee will not be
doing anything
over this summer
um but we will be coming back in
September and would it would be helpful
if we were
able to move ourselves further along in
terms of of what we might want to pursue
the vice chair has been helpful I think
in giving us some information about how
you one might Define the reasons for uh
a subpoena and the alternative is
um are there reasons
for uh
for this commissioner to have
of the Department of Education to have
um subpoena power I believe it is very
important that as we do this
work we recognize that our concern is
institutional it is not
personal
and therefore whoever is Con whoever or
whomever whomever is
um commissioner today may may not be
commissioner a year from now and we have
to make sure that what we have in place
is something that respects the
institution first
and the powers that we give to the
institution
can then be applied by
anyone who's occupying the appropriate
positions of power and and it's
I want to make sure that nothing we do
could be construed in any other way
but recognizing commitment to the
institution
and also acknowledging changes in the
world
um
so I'm I didn't expect to be able to say
at the end of this okay I see clearly
where we should where we should go let's
just do this and didn't expect that but
um I'm a little
Ron plus I guess about
being able to say to the committee okay
you do this and you do that because I
don't see it um
and perhaps other people do but I would
hope that you would
use this as a as a helpful opportunity
to see how complicated it is
and then we can come back maybe
reinvigorate and ready to figure out
where we want to go does that make sense
to people
anybody else have anything they want to
say yes
so I guess
I I heard that we needed you know it was
a recommendation to put in some
safeguards in place but I guess I'd like
to understand you know after hearing
what we've heard does everybody feel
like this is a path that we should you
know look into you know going further
with this bill or is there still
hesitation with the bill I'd just like
to understand kind of where everybody is
at is that a fair question
oh any questions fair and there's no
obligation for anybody to answer it so
representative Tripp
no correct me if I'm wrong
but I believe that the intent of the
current bill
was just to give the
Department of Education
the
capability
to submit a
complaint
no no you're you have the original Bill
we had a non-germaine Amendment which
completely changed this around what the
non-germaine Bell did was it gave
subpoena power to the depart to the
commissioner of the education
commissioner to subpoena documents
persons and other things related to
violations with the code of conduct
let me see if I can pull up like exactly
it was very short so it said
um
I have it okay perfect but uh
was this adopted by the committee it
wasn't but that was kind of the
direction of why we retained the bill I
think we had decided that the initial
bill was completely not needed but that
there was need for the this non-germaine
amendment
um
you know to have the authority to issue
subpoenas for Relevant documents and
items for the
code of conduct so it has nothing to do
with the
Department of
the Human Rights Commission no
I learned something today
everybody should learn something new
sometimes I learned so many new things
that there's no room in my brain
so
all right well that
changes my focus thank you okay anybody
else
I guess to the dude yeah
um
to represent Top's question I think is
so I
I guess I I'm still in the position of
it's it's hard for me to to
representative trips up
point it's hard for me to escape the
history of this
um in the sense that it's where where
the original bill is and then and then
what the um
amendment is in terms of subpoena power
and and not be a little a little bit
hesitant or cautious
um
about about proceeding have having said
that and setting setting that aside to
representative chairperson Smith
point about separating the personal and
the institutional I I think we should
take take that to heart although it
seems to be a bit difficult in this
particular context
um but
and setting that aside
um I still feel like I need more
information about what if any
other states are doing what what sort of
what what it would exist like what you
know not and in terms of the reasons for
it
um which
um you know I'm not
we did hear testimony from the from reps
or from investigator Farrell
but but I also
it seems seems to be conflicting at some
points in my view about the success he
was having
um and so I'm still a little bit
uh fuzzy about the need and I think the
one thing that we come to Concord to do
is not past things that that we don't
need but um
so so that's where I'm at but having
said that I would certainly um if I
thank the website for outlining some
starting the thought process I guess if
you will about that sort of thing
thank you and I I just want to ask so I
guess
where this was completely non-germaine
is there an ability for us to just
kill the other Bill and just start from
the beginning with a bill that actually
relates to what we actually need because
I I do
um relate to what you're saying in terms
of the path well every I think it's
confusing for everybody why we started
out with something that's completely
unrelated to this and now we're down a
completely new Amendment with it it
almost just seems like we're about to
start you know in September with putting
in new lslr lsrs does it make sense to
just start fresh with something you know
that would have like all these
parameters and then actually having
testimony on the actual parameters and
everything because
I think it's for me it's hard to know
like are there going to be some
unintended consequences without having
you know a full hearing to kind of vet
the legislation of how we would put
something in I don't know I what I I'm a
freshman so I'm not sure if that's
something that's even doable I'd love to
hear is well I think the point that you
make is is quite valid and we've seen
here on the committee the confusion that
we have about the underlying bill and
the non-germaine amendment
um that you know to begin with creates a
very complicated issue for us
um there is perfectly appropriate and
there's nothing that could stop anyone
on this committee
from in the second week of September
filing an um
uh a request for a bill
to give the commissioner of Education
subpoena power in certain
um
areas
um and so could do that the Commit This
committee can
um
adopt the underlying bill which I don't
think anyone thinks there's any need for
could adopt the non-germaine amendment
where there seems to be some difference
of opinion or
um
could
could itl the entire kitten caboodle or
um
amend come in with an amendment
to the underlying Bill if we thought we
wanted to use that
as a vehicle for something so all of
those options are open to us they're
different time
restrictions I mean you know to submit a
new completely new bill that's September
11th to 15th I think
to have a this committee report on a
retained bill is the 15th or the 17th of
November I keep on looking over it at my
Guru
um but I believe that that's that's true
and all of that is possible and it
occurs to me that we might have a better
sense after the summer of what makes
what in fact makes more sense I don't
think I don't think right now there's
any unanimity
in this group and of course we then have
to go to the full committee and if we're
not
um comfortable together we certainly
know that the full committee is not
going to be comfortable together
um so uh my one remaining question is
for is do you think that it would be
in a reasonable with a reasonable amount
of time on your part which means about
35 seconds since you have so many other
things on your plate
to get either from ncsl or from another
source
um
information as to
subpoena power under these circumstances
in within the you know public education
system
having said that I realized that none of
it might be relevant because in so many
ways what we do in public education in
this state differs from what happens in
other states including Authority
ultimate Authority so it might be that
there's no parallel experiences and I
understand that but
could you take a quick look and see
ah good better safe
that would be terrific and if you do
find something could I ask that you send
it on to us rather than waiting till
September but send it on to us when you
get it because that will help us in our
idle moments of trying to to sort this
through
good beach reading exactly I'd like to
question you about good speech reading
and bad Beach reading but okay anything
else that anyone wants to share if not I
expect that I will see everybody sitting
at this side of the table on Thursday
some of us we might see tomorrow at the
other subcommittee meetings
um but do show up on Thursday
um anything else
if not
um I adjourn this subcommittee at 2 35.
goodbye
all right